thank you for having me professors and
students I am an alumni alumni of the
Stanford engineering school but I must
warn you that I remember was a very good
engineer I came here for engineering
because at the time when I came here the
government of India only gave exchange
for an engineering education for an
undergraduate but what I enjoyed most
about my engineering education I was
telling Dean Ross about this is the
broadening opportunity one god as an
engineer which opportunity is not
available in India we tend to get
funneled into engineering from year one
unlike most engineering schools in the
United States I had to leave Stanford in
66 because my father suddenly died and
had to take over some family
responsibilities of the company we're a
small company then today our run rate in
an elaborately growing company I think
run rate becomes more relevant than the
sales of the previous year is over three
billion dollars and we are growing in
excess of thirty four thirty five
percent a year our market we are listed
on the Indian stock exchanges and we are
also listed on the New York Stock
Exchange and the market capitalization
of our company's little over twenty
billion u.s. dollars which really puts
us in the league in terms of software
consultancy of the Accenture plus in
terms of at least market capitalization
if not in terms of revenue size
since our entry into information
technology in 1981 we have grown in
revenue but we have also grown in head
count the total number of people which
we have in our information technology
business today globally and in India are
in excess of 60,000 people and the
interesting statistics is that they
drink 1,400 gallons of coffee a day and
they drink over 3,300 gallons of tea a
day roughly equal in terms of size how
we'll be able to do what we did and you
know I don't think we are unique in this
there are the companies in India who
have repeated this and we are finding
now that many other companies in India
have built up a scale of ambition which
is completely different than the scale
of ambition which they had two years
back we are seeing this happening in
pharmaceuticals we are seeing this
happening on a more smaller base in bio
technologies we are seeing this
happening in auto in salaries and
recently with a very large acquisition
we have seen it happen in steel very
interestingly in the quantum anyway
quantum acquisition which our company
the company in India did and I think
this firing of ambition in terms of the
globalization of Indian companies has in
part being generated by the success of
the software and the IT and able
services industry and I figured we said
the example and fellow businessmen
figure that these if these fools in
software can do it so can we
which is really the quantum change and
it's it's a very pleasant quantum change
in the scale of ambition of Indian
business leaders particularly over the
past two years how do these changes
happen in every market at every juncture
incumbent companies dominate almost
every industry established customer
relationships well entrenched products
powerful brands powerful brands
and significant scale advantages make
these companies appear invincible to
aspiring entrants yet time and time
again and particularly you see this in
the United States and particularly you
see it in Silicon Valley upstarts create
a disruption in the marketplace a very
strong disruption in the marketplace
innovating on delivery innovating on
process innovating on technology
innovating on products and very very
often innovating on business models
which i think is becoming the most
important determinant of success in the
marketplace and they change the rules of
the game and because they've changed the
rules of the game they have a quality of
a competitive space for consumers
innovation means higher quality and
better value for goods more efficient
services both private and public and
higher standards of living for
businessmen innovation means sustained
or improved growth higher profits and in
our interconnected world innovation
improves lives here are some examples
there are interesting simple examples
poor fishermen in Kerala which is a
southernmost tip of India use cell
phones now on the way back from their
catch so that they can find out where
they can get the highest prices and head
straight for that part of the market
straight from the sea we are finding
farmers now subscribing to cell phones
and they do that in India in the small
villages because typically farmers in
small villages used to sell their
produce in the local market which is
called among the ma and di and they're
very often found that the mundi
wholesale is used to exploit them and on
rates today the farmer before he brings
his produce to the Mundi would check up
what are the rates in competing markets
from a relation or a friend in the
competing markets and then decide
whether he wants to sell the produce
what is the cutoff at what he wants to
put sell the produce or take his cart
Bullock cart to a Mundi which is a
little further away because he's able to
get a rate realization which is better
the more enterprising of them will go to
the extent of also trying to follow
closing rate on the Chicago Board of
Trade the previous day to see whether
any trends are building up and whether
he can expect better rates going forward
and it's worth sitting on his produce in
Bangladesh Grameen Phone which is which
started with microfinance and now has
extended its reach enabled mobile phone
connectivity to over 40,000 villages
mobile public phones are managed by
village phone women who run it as a
business these micro entrepreneurs buy
the phone with a loan from the Grameen
Bank and then sell the use of the phone
on a per use basis or on a per call
basis because people cannot afford to
buy the unit value of the phone
initiative of each opal by a leading
agricultural produce company which
incidentally happens to have built his
fortune in selling cigarettes links
directly with rural farmers for the
procurement of agricultural produce and
agricultural outputs like soya like
coffee like prawns grass food grains
transactions worth 100 million dollars
we carried out through these show pods
in the first year and this company is
rapidly scaling this offer what really
is innovation how is it different from
creativity the simplest definition I
have come across is that creativity is
about making new things whereas
innovation is about doing new things
innovation comes from applying
creativity or applying thought it is
about action versus just ideas it is
about implementing as much as it is
about design
similarly innovation need not be
restricted to products or to technology
to me innovation applies to productivity
innovation applies to service it applies
to service models which India is
becoming a pioneer on it applies to
financial disciplines it applies to
employee attitudes and renew
it applies to business models most
importantly we pros an example of
business model innovation we pioneered
ways to deliver services like research
and development testing infrastructure
management and application development
and maintenance and remotely today as a
company we are the largest third-party
R&D service provider in the world to
multinational R&D companies we have more
than 16 thousand engineers in this area
the digitization of the world along with
globalization with India China and
Russia deciding to enter the global
economy has meant that the emerging
markets in this digital world are
becoming code rooms for innovation both
in terms of product design and in terms
of business processes required to
deliver these products to the market so
how does the leader create a culture of
innovation I can share some thoughts
with you based on our experience and
based on some of my personal experiences
innovation is just not about incremental
improvements in the course of daily
operations or one-off new brilliant
ideas innovation is a culture that needs
to be created consciously and pursued
assiduously
by the organization and always always
nurtured and that's probably the most
difficult thing to do as one gets larger
and as one gets more bureaucratic first
we need to appreciate that all success
creates its own gravity and please don't
underestimate this it is easy to believe
that what has succeeded so far must
continue to succeed in the future as
well this builds up a kind of dominant
logic that is comfortable to the
thinking of the management any new idea
will be pulled to the ground with the
force of gravity the first step
therefore is to confront the gravity if
we can inspire everyone around us with a
vision that is truly exciting
the feeling of complacency gets whittled
and tends to come off this can provide
the escape velocity to counter the
gravitational forces it can also create
new energy to dig out and give life to
many ideas lying beneath layers of
bureaucracy second ideas can come from
everywhere and from anyway even the
finance team no insult meant but I just
find in all organizations a huge amount
of jokes a bit round as an ad scheme I
don't know why but always seem to be the
case in every organization the customer
is a great source for ideas the customer
can actually participate in his getting
better satisfaction provided we can
listen to the customer and what he or
she has to say and I think this is the
most important thing in terms of
customer visits in terms of customer
research is how do you get the customer
to say things or indicate things or give
nuances of things which are really
unsaid and very often the customer
himself or herself does not know
about it but that is the source of truly
very very interesting ideas
third we need to actively bring in
people who are not clones of people
already in the organization and that
means a very very concerted focus in
terms of one's resourcing or recruiting
teams because typically all of us
recruit what we are most comfortable
with all of us try to reject what we are
not comfortable with and if one wants to
generate innovation in an organization
it is absolutely essential that once
gets diversity diversity in terms of
culture diversity in terms of age
diversities in terms of sex and
diversities in terms of the way a person
thinks and acts very often this
diversity is rejected by most
organization and particularly
organizations with scale rapidly because
for them the process of recruitment
becomes a very uniform standardized
process of headcount additions but in
addition to selecting the right people
and getting them on stream I think it is
very critical that these people are
protected if these people are not
protected in an organization by
leadership by supervisors by management
and by top management they tend to
wither away and leave the organization
and generally the effect of this is much
worse off than what would have happened
if you had not selected them in the
first place
because that then becomes the image of
the organization that the organization
cannot absorb diversity but such people
are invaluable to the innovation process
forth top management needs to
demonstrate its commitment to innovation
consistently and always people hear what
others say but act on what others do the
commitment must be intrinsically and go
beyond just providing budgets and
physical assets we need to constantly
reinforce the field that we are keep
thinking differently if we have to
survive and if we have to grow fifth in
terms of some principles of our
experience or innovation
is the way is the day of the isolated
innovative elevator is getting less and
less important we need to innovate we
need to enroll support we need to work
in teams we need to work in
cross-functional cross border cross
global teams to be able to be successful
in innovation sixth we must actually
encourage our people to constructively
challenge ideas once they have reached a
certain stage too early a confrontation
will kill the idea too late a
confrontation will probably involve an
expenditure which could have been
avoided but the intermediate stage and
the key the trick is really in trying to
figure out what is this intermediate see
it should be too early and we do late
this helps us to look at the ideas from
various angles and bring out nuances
that could be critical while
implementing them seventh we must allow
for creative failure when it comes to
generating ideas it is inevitable no one
likes failure particularly business
leaders but unfortunately all evidence
suggests that it is impossible to
generate few good ideas without a lot of
bad ideas and bad ideas are expensive
but they have to be tolerated as the
physics Nobel Prize winner faman said I
try to fail as fast as I can
that is the best way to move forward on
a new idea fail as fast as you can
failure should be forgiven and forgotten
as long as the lessons are remembered
and recycled finally we must have a
clear process to communicate the
directions and areas where new ideas of
sort where new ideas are to be focused
so employees can be realistic in their
assessment of the opportunities at Wipro
we have set up an innovation council
that acts like an internal VC for
innovation the council has a clearly
defined goals and clearly defined
objectives little fun projects that will
improve business productivity for Wipro
and its customers
improve our ability to win deals and
reduce cost of delivery the pros
innovation initiative and the Centers of
Excellence currently have we have a team
close to about 500 people dedicated
professionals on a portfolio of
innovation products projects in the
areas of process improvements in the
areas process improvements such as lean
technologies process improvement such as
software engineering execution the
factory model for delivering
standardized service new service lines
business solutions in R&D development of
IPs and patents in the areas of wireless
applications areas of mobile telepathy
etc at Wipro we attempt to
institutionalize the spirit of
innovation through our innovation
initiative about six years back and it
has moved reasonably well it could have
moved better today innovation accounts
and this is defined quite tightly
otherwise one can really blow it up
accounts for about five percent of our
revenues and our target is that within
three years we are taking it up to ten
percent of our revenues because we find
it important engine of growth last year
we file 458 invention disclosures on
behalf of our customers and ourselves
Wipro has been able to create a
successful track record of innovating
service delivery models being among the
first to remote deliver R&D
infrastructure outsourcing testing and
Business Process Outsourcing finally to
conclude as Gary Hamel puts it
businesses are good at getting better
but poor and getting different it is
very difficult for successful
organizations to develop disruptive
innovations that would threaten the
basis of their success often they are
put out of business when some similar
company or smaller company develops a
radically new technology which employs
working in a booming telecom company in
the 1990s would have suggested that free
voice over Internet telephony would be
something that they could develop it
took a startup Skype to make a success
of this radical idea I have found that
people excel when they are provided a
fair free and a political environment if
we Proheat strive to provide an open
culture which encourages diversity of
opinions operating as we do in global
environment and 80% of our revenue comes
from outside of India 83% of our revenue
we try to bring the best practise of our
customers associates and internals and
work to build an X practice thank you
for your any author I'd be very happy to
take questions and they need not
and they can be open-ended questions
they need not be related to the specific
subject matter of what I've talked about
yes sir your your company in your
industry is grown in astronomical rates
and many analysts expect it to continue
to do so this clearly has huge
implications for your company for your
industry for India and the rest of the
companies that are delivering these
services what implications does this
have for the customer
if the offshore outsource IT service
sector grows to 50% of global IT
spending
how will company's internal IT
organizations be affected how can
companies use IT as a competitive
advantage in that case you don't let me
just get you some broad perspectives on
this because I've been meeting the media
and I was in some senior level meetings
in New York yesterday and day before I
think a very important factor which you
must appreciate is a huge shortage is
building up of IT professionals in
Western nations please do not
underestimate how serious the problem is
you are going back already to the days
which were there in the dot-com boom and
I'll give you some leading indicators of
that and these are published figures
Accenture is today running attrition
levels of 19% on a global basis and
properly higher
attrition levels in the United States
iBM is running about 1415 percent
attrition levels we are running 15
percent attrition levels of our 6,500
employees in the United States higher
than what we run in India it's and these
are people primarily with h-1b visas of
Indian origin with Indian passports the
serious shortage is building up of IT
professionals in Western nations and
prime reason for that is Western culture
is not encouraging or students are not
getting motivated to get into
engineering adequate number and those
which are in engineering are not wanting
to specialize in computer
science fact what number one is that
part of this scarcity of talent is being
serviced by outsourcing because
countries such as India countries such
as China produce engineers in a scale
proportion five times what US produces
four times what u.s. produce depending
on the figures which US produces second
I think what we must appreciate is that
there is a certain part of work which
does gets done in information services
which has to be done with the customer
on the customer site it can be the
outsource surround to the customer
physically surround to the customer or
it can be outsourced remotely but the
proportion which has to be done at
customer site would probably be on a
composite basis about 40% of the
headcount for consultancy is probably
about 80% of the headcount so you're
your number which you said that half the
IT work could get eventually outsourced
is properly a little exaggerated
probably about 40 percent can be but if
you're getting into a situation where
you are running into scarcities I just
see a global sourcing model as extremely
strong productivity tool and a survival
tool and it is something which which
which I think is inevitable and it's
just not based on cost arbitrage it's
just based on talent arbitrage was based
on talent leverage does that answer what
you were asking for
yes sir
I have a question related to changing
mindsets we in our company we outsource
a lot of IT business a few years ago to
Wipro and then the general attitude was
we get the easy problems to Wipro and we
keep a second line of support in Dublin
where we'll keep the tough problems to
ourselves so we get the easy stuff over
to Bangalore how much of this attitude
and mindset do you find it to be a
challenge in your business and you see a
changing over time or there's a huge
change over time there's a huge change
over time but you know companies go
through a phase you know in fact we find
in Europe and we have about nine centers
in Europe which we call nearshore
centres very physically close to the
customer or the concentration of
customers it in the first phase very
conservative customers particularly in
Europe particularly in continental
Europe would prefer to work with a
global sourcing company such as Wipro or
Infosys or TCS with physical proximity
to their headquarters or physical
proximity to the place where the work is
done which is where a nearshore Center
comes in and at phase 2 they will be
willing to move the work offshore and at
phase 3 they would be willing to get
into more high quality work I think
that's a natural process of
confidence-building within the
organization but if you ask me you know
India will do this you're about 30
billion of software and BPO exports call
centers as well as background processing
if you take software of this about I
think 18 billion would be software
services all our BPO services are
completely offshore and the processes
which are getting offshore or BPO
services are getting more and more
sophisticated including analytics
including pre preparation by McKinsey of
all the presentations to their customers
increasing 60% of the presentations of
complex solutions being done in the back
room but in software services I would
say of the 18 or 20
you may be about 30% would be quality
work which is in a way the heart of the
organization to give you an example and
this is not just trying to market vapor
oh we are very large in R&D services and
we work with 10 of the 11 largest
telecom companies in the world today and
we are working on next-generation switch
design and next-generation cellphone
designs and a part of our work which is
significantly increasing in terms of
proportion is on a service level
agreement basis it's not on a time and
material basis we take responsibility
for in deliverables we take
responsibility for say n cell phone
design and get paid a significant part
of our fees on the success of what we
have Co worked with our partner on so
our front end fees are even often lower
than our cost so the models are changing
as customers get more confident they do
more and American customers particularly
because of the track record of having
worked in this offshoring model are
increasingly getting into sophisticated
work including in the area of
infrastructure support one of our
fastest growing lines today is global
infrastructure support which typically
the IBM or the EDS or the cab Germany
does and the size of the contracts is
increasing so it's not the 40 50 million
dollar sub contracts which are being
considered for offshoring is the two
hundred three hundred four hundred
million dollar contracts not yet the 1
billion dollar contracts yes sir
could you talk a bit about the
transition from a small family company
to what you are today you know I think
one advantage which we had is we
completely turned turtle on our business
and we went into information I came on
the scene in repro in 67 and we were
primarily a vegetable oil company it was
very small
the initial phase which we went through
was transforming a very commoditized
business which dealt with only
wholesalers to building a very strong
consumer brand business which dealt with
retailers who dealt with customers and
with very strong inputs of branding and
very strong inputs of distribution that
continued to be a little more
traditional part of the business but it
added on a lot of people in marketing
and sales which we never had before and
much more sophistication in financial
processes the advantage in that business
also was that we've again turning the
business into a completely different
approach Reserve is the market so we had
to recruit people who were professionals
for it made the entire process of
transition much easier we've entered the
information technology business in 1980
and that team we built virtually from
scratch we transferred people in human
resources and finance and a little bit
in logistics but again we were able to
intake fresh people fresh leadership
fresh people from campus I think the
fact that we were transiting businesses
so much made it much easier to be making
a movement from a so called family
managed company to what we consider very
professional company today so it was not
as hard as it appeared to be and we grew
very rapidly so that also again made it
easier then we made it a point not to
employ in the company any family members
so the signal was very clear that this
is the message which top management and
ownership is communicating upfront and
standing by that message in terms of
it's better
in the current prevailing environment
that exists in India and the software
industry what future do you see for
entrepreneurs in India especially when
you consider global clients who place
their beds increasingly with giants like
Infosys and Wipro and what suggestions
do you have for the entrepreneurial
talent which is currently growing in
India and is probably contributing to
the attrition rates in your companies
Thanks I didn't catch the last part of
the question so a lot of youth today in
India are quitting large giants like
Infosys Wipro and big brand names to
start their own companies what advice do
you have for them as they struggle to
compete with the bigger companies you
know I can give you some overviews I'm
not very wide into opportunities for
entrepreneurs to start off in
information technology in India but I
can give you some broad indicators
there's a huge amount of venture capital
funds in a huge amount of private equity
funds in India now both by Indian banks
or Indian investment bankers whether it
be ICICI or HDFC etc but by virtually
all the large private equity bankers
have offices and large funds allocated
for India as well as venture capitalists
are looking at specialized areas in
India so I do not think that if you have
a good idea and if you have the passion
to make a success of that idea you'll be
wanting in funds the response you will
get those I think what you need to do is
to be clear how much passion you have or
people like you have intending to make a
success of it's not going to be on the
doorstep it's not going to be
necessarily much easier than doing it in
the United States the markets are
competitive the quality of evaluation
for opportunities by the funds has got
now sophisticated they will not put
money on yours they've got enough
burning
and if you want to be in the area of
services my strong advice is for God's
sake focus you cannot build another way
processed out you know you figure out
you figure out that you know in the area
of services you want to target either in
the area of Technology or in the area of
enterprise a specific segment where you
build a base with one or two customers
you can build a credibility with and
then expand on those customers I just
find you know we've had some people who
left us and have come back to us and
they try to build clones of Wipro and
the custom is consolidating there's no
question on that and the rich are
getting richer and the big are getting
bigger and you see it in terms of
movement of the top five companies from
India in terms of share of exports it's
probably going up by about between one
and three percent a year which is a
typical indication of what is happening
not because we're naturally smarter but
because our brand helps us in being able
to give higher security to the customer
which who is making a rich decision but
there are opportunities but the
opportunities are going to be as tough
as the opportunities you see anywhere
else in the world it's not on a platter
for you yes sir
well and in the in the past era India
has been taking over the business
process outsourcing and the question is
do you envision in the future India
moving out not out of the business
process outsourcing but more into the
product ownership itself and product
innovation and directly heading for the
consumers you know it information
technology I think of this thirty
billion dollar exports which will take
place this year I think in the IT area
products would account for probably
under three or four percent of it why is
that happening I think they're just more
low-hanging fruit and services said
simple as that
it's easier to make money in services
with lower risk than it is in products
the bets are bigger than certainties
more but I think there's also more
fundamental reason for it product
innovation and product success is very
very linked to markets even you have to
be on line with the customer and to be
sitting in India and to be online with
an American customer or a European
customer you're using your uniqueness of
advantage of a remote delivery model
very severely so what are you really
bringing to the table which is unique if
in terms of access to the customer you
have to build a very strong base in the
consuming market so a very large part of
your course arbitrage or cost advantage
gets whittled down to is much risk you
and there is low-hanging fruit so
whether we like it or not we are
gravitating towards where the risks are
less than the rewards are more I do not
see India emerging as a large product
innovation country unfortunately but the
nice thing about it is that every
product company is trying to build a
service business I mean it's a capsule
to Universal trend every product company
wants the advantage of an annuity
business and generally margins tend to
be better in services and they tend to
be in products they are exceptions of
course the Oracles are the exceptions
the Microsoft are the exceptions but
they built a huge critical mass and they
also trying to reap an install base
through services
yes sir
yes given the extreme growth that you
quoted at the start of your talk the 30
plus percent I was wondering if you
might be able to share a couple specific
examples of the challenges that you face
and the organization faces trying to
deal with that whether it be simply in
hiring you know talent at that rate and
so on so if you could talk a little bit
about what your role is in that and how
the organization is dealing with that
you know scaling in a services business
is a huge challenge and just give you an
example we have 60,000 plus employees in
our services business and if you're
growing even at 30% a and I'm using
conservative figures technically you
should be adding 18,000 employees a year
plus attrition and attrition levels are
running in India today at about 13 14 %
so you know you add that to the 18,000
people you then you deduct productivity
I mean you try to drive for 8 9 percent
a year you probably end up with 6 7% a
year five 6% to you including trying to
build some amount of non-linearity in
your business models so your net net
adding or 20,000 people a year or more
than 20,000 people you revisit about 160
engineering campuses we visit about 25
business schools including
internationally and engineering campuses
internationally but our volume of intake
internationally is much lower I think
what is relatively manageable to do is
scaling recruitment standards targeting
recruitment I mean you can build it to
scale you can be able to scale well the
induction process you know we have a
virtual university for induction for
college graduates and a virtual in
university for induction of lateral
hires you can you can scale induction
into quality processes so that you give
a uniform face of our customers concern
I think the biggest challenge is to
scale cultural continuity which is very
important from a customer point of view
and particularly important in a service
organization very very important it
requires a huge amount of engaged
meant of supervisory time middle
management time senior management time
and top management time so far people
like me are concerned and in a growth
situation you have very pressing
dynamics of competition in very pressing
dynamics of group it's not an easy
challenge and I think you get into some
compromises along the way that we are
finding as one of the biggest challenges
which we face you know as an example
McKinsey did some studies on this and I
think Mackenzie has globally about
twenty or twenty four thousand people
and they found that they could not
manage a growth beyond twenty percent a
year without compromising on what
McKinsey stood for interesting I think
that is the big challenge now the more
higher quality work which you do the
more you are not running a factory and
the more the cultural issues become more
and more important so the problem will
get more acute or more challenging as we
start going up the food chain and still
try to grow a 30% to you now whether we
can do it or not I don't know it
probably require the next generation of
people in leadership to be able to do it
better
yes sir
so I have a question about the ownership
of a pro so even though it's listed and
it's professionally run the family still
owns of the majority of a pro so my
question is going forward how do you see
the ownership changing and the
leadership transitioning now I really
don't know that's an honest answer to
give you because we are we are running
very cash flow surplus for your free
cash flow and we are able to finance
acquisitions and we're able to finance
growth through internal approvals we are
listed on the new york stock exchange we
are listed on the Indian stock exchanges
whether part of the ownership will come
down yes of course part of the ownership
will come down through two simple
mechanisms one is employee stock Awards
we give stock award was the stock
options now we switch to stock awards
and we give them every year and we give
them between 1 and 3 percent of our
total capitalization and second is
through our funding of our foundation d
Azim Premji foundation into which we are
constantly denote donating shares which
again leads to dilution and that will
continue and if we need to raise money
we will raise money and get diluted
further but we Pro is a good bet in
terms of investment so it becomes a
little difficult defined alternatives
which are better
if better
I can use a mic please we were fortunate
enough to hear the Finance Minister of
India speak here at Stanford a few days
ago and he talked about who do you cheat
on huh
hmm he spoke about no offense meant
either I was so so my question has he
spoke a lot about how two things are
very important to him as he thinks about
India's future one is maintaining the 8%
growth rate of India but number two is
to make sure that that doesn't come at
the expense of the social balance and
how sort of all segments of society you
know should maybe be benefiting
collectively and I think this is
reflecting a lot of the policy decisions
that are being made right now in India
and I was wondering if you could speak a
little about how you found you know
managing the business like yours it's
growing as rapidly unis such such a
power player in a regulatory environment
that reflects that kind of a mentality
you know I don't think in they're such a
regular regulatory environment which is
made out to be
I think our image is worse than our
facts frankly you know I think we do a
very poor job of selling ourselves you
just take the contrast with China you
know we have an operation in Beijing and
we have an operation in Shanghai and we
have about 170 fortune 500 as our global
customers and I do get a chance to
interact with them with the leadership
there and the CEOs there fairly
frequently because there are important
customer base for us the general
experience is that India is under
projected in terms of its liberalization
but equally important the experiences
that China gives with one hand and takes
away with to consistently they find it's
much easier to make money in India than
it is to make money in China there's
much more predictability there's much
more transparency in the laws I think
fortunately for us as a country a
political leadership is getting more and
more divorced from the economic engine
and the economic engine continues
irrespective of them and there's no
offense to them but they are relevant
they're very few industries
regulated and I think too much of the
regulation is spun around the fact that
insurance is not permitting 49% for our
ownership or retail is not opening up to
multinational investments but these are
political compulsions which the
government is sensitive to retail is a
political compulsion because we have 21
million retailers in our country which
employs a father a mother two children
in the afternoon who drop in after
school and one paid employee and whether
you like it or not - retail formats
which are large will displace jobs the
contrary is that they will generate much
more farm income and much more farm
value add so you'll see properly
creation of jobs there but politically
it's difficult for the government to
build a cat and I think this is getting
a lot of foreign visibility and
therefore causing an impression that we
are very bureaucratic I don't think we
are speaking to the mic madam quickly
the one thing that would spring to mind
that could really affect our business is
regulation around education and with the
reservations of the you know system at
the universities that that's effect on
your ability to source quality talent in
India in the future does that does that
make sense yeah this is a current set of
politics which is going around on this
but please understand that we've had
some amount of reservation around
education and reservation around jobs
now for more than 30 years I think what
has just caused a bit of a wake-up is
that they're trying to increase the
proportion of it I think part of the
solution is that the people in
leadership people in industry must be
more proactive on that in terms of
participating in terms of creating a
little more free and little more
encouraging competitive environment for
people who come from societies or parts
of societies where they are
disadvantaged in terms of their
background and therefore not on equal
competition I think we reach some
equilibrium on this but part of the
equilibrium will be that the reservation
quota
increase but nowhere as close to what is
being talked about at this point of time
is that a good step or a bad step I
think it's a retrograde step it's a
manageable step yes go ahead
these days everywhere you see in the
newspapers and magazines that everyone
says that this century belongs to India
in China and that the professionals who
are studying here in America they have
already started thinking about moving
back to India and China so what do you
how do you foresee this trend in the
future I can tell you you know four
years back when the market was hot like
the market is hot today for IT
professionals we were running at
efficient levels of about 14 15% and 30%
to 40% of that was to jobs in the United
States offer higher studies in the
United States today if you're running at
rich in levels of about 13 14 % under 1%
is for studies or jobs in the United
States so that trend is completely
reversed why is because job
opportunities in India better and
compensation levels are much better now
so people are not looking at us job is a
major opportunity to make a lot of money
anymore
I think that trend will continue but the
interesting trend that we are finding
and I think some of our colleagues also
in the industry of finding more
experienced people today are wanting to
come back to India they wanted to come
back to India because job opportunities
are better and they wanting to come back
to India because compensation levels
have become so attractive that they can
even at a middle a management level
afford a decent standard of living in
India and that standard of living is
improving because costs are not going up
commensurately so that trend is very
much there it's a good trend and not too
familiar with China but China is also
using some very strong incentives to get
back talent which we did not we don't
find necessary to do we are getting it
to a natural process thank you very much
thank